[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره الظهيره من
العربيه ساعتنا الاخباريه المفصله نبداها
بابرز العناوين
تواصل واعمال قمه مجموعه العشرين
باندونيسيا ومسوده البيان الختامي تدعو
لتجنب التهديد بالسلاح النووي
سعيون امريكيه لدينات الحرب في اوكرانيا
ببيان قمه العشرين وازيلنسكي يقترحوا
تبادل جميع السجناء مع روسيا
ومن ملفات الظهيره البحريه الامريكيه تعلن
ضبط 70 طنا من وقود الصواريخ في قارب
المتجه من ايران الى اليمن
وفي نشاط الظهيره ايضا في انتخابات
الجمهوريون على بعد مقعد واحد من استعاده
اغلبيه مجلس النواب
اهلا بكم نبدا بحدث الساعه تتواصل في بالي
الاندونيسيه اعمل قمه مجموعه ال 20 يعتبرت
بيان قمه العشرين التي تعقد في جزيره بالي
باندونيسيا ان استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والتهديد بها غير مقبول رجاء في مسوده
بيان القمه ان معظم الاعضاء يدينون وبشده
الحرب في اوكرانيا داعيه الى ضروره تنديد
صفقه الحبوب الاوكرانيه واضفت ايضا ان
المجموعه
على الاقتصاد العالمي وخلال افتتاح القمه
احب رئيس الاندونيسيه
قاده المجموعه على انهاء الحرب وتجنب حرب
بارده اخرى بين القوه الكبرى
اليوم
القادرين على تحقيق النجاح ام اننا سوف
نكون في مواجهه فشل اخر اضافه الى مجموعه
اعمالنا الفاشله السابقه بنظري هذه القمه
يجب ان لا تفشل اندونيسيا عملت ما بوسعها
لسد هذه القوه الواسعه لكن النجاح لا يمكن
ان يتحقق الا اذا عملنا جميعا وبالتزام
على تضييق هو في خلافاتنا ونقدم شيئا
ملموسا يعود بالنفع على العالم بصفاتنا
نحمل رئاسه قمه مجموعه ال 20 فان الحوار
هو الكفيل بسد الفجوه في خلافاتنا وهذا لن
يكون خيارا فان التعاون سوف يكون مطلوبا
وتقع على كاهلنا مسؤوليات تجاه العالم
اجمع المسؤوليه تعني انه يجب علينا ان
نسجل الستار على الحرب واذا لم تنتهي
فسيصعب علينا ان نمضي قدما وان نحقق
الاستقرار من اجل مستقبل الاجيال القادمه
يجب علينا الا ندخل العالم في دهاليز
الصراع او في حرب بارده جديده
ان العالم يواجه تحديات غير عاديه يواجه
ازمه تلو الاخرى فجائحه كوفيت 19 لن تنتهي
بعد وهناك ازمه الامن الغذائي والامن
المالي وامن الطاقه التي اخذت العالم على
حين غاره ولا سيما في البلدان الناميه
كذلك موضوع الاسمده يجب ان لا يؤخذ بكل
سهوله وان لم نتخذ اجراءات مباشره لضمان
امدادات الاسمده بصوره كافيه وباسعار ضمن
المتناول فان العام القادم سيكون عاما اشد
صعوبه والازمه التي نعيشها اليوم قد تصبح
اشد وطاتا وازمه الغد قد تكون متجليه في
المواد الغذائيه الامر الذي سوف يؤثر على
المحاصيل في كافه انحاء العالم ولا سيامه
بالنسبه للدول الناميه التي ستواجه صعوبات
وتحديات كبيره
من جانبه حضر الرئيس الصيني في جيبينج
مجموعه العشرين من تحويل الغذاء والطاقه
الى سلاح وقال رئيس الصينيه امام القمه ان
بلده تعارض تاسيس مشكله الغذاء والطاقه
بينما قرر في الوقت ذاته التعبير عن
معارضته لسياسه العقوبات الغربيه على
روسيا واشدد بينج على ضروره ان تعمل دول
مجموعه العشرين على الحد من تداعيات رفع
اسعار الفائده خلال مساعدها للسيطره على
التضخم
وعلى هامشي فعاليات القمه التقى ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وجرى خلال اللقاء استعراض والعلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين وافاق التعاون في
شتى المجالات الى جانبه بحث مستجدات
الاقليميه والدوليه والجهود المبذوله
تجاهها
ومن جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه يبقى معنا في
التغطيه المستمره منفض العربيه الى هناك
ازمير محمد الطميحي مرحبا بك محمد مجددا
قمه يمتزج فيها الاقتصاد بالسياسه ما هي
اهم العناوين للنقاشات التي تدور للتعامل
مع الازمات الدوليه الحاليه الاقتصاديه
منها والسياسيه محمد
العربيه
قبل قليل كانت الجنس الافتتاحيه هي التي
حددت المعالم الرئيسيه
لقمه العشرين من خلال تصريحات الرئيس قبل
ساعات من الان ومع انطلاق هذه القمه سربت
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ما قالت بانه
المسود مسوده البيان الختامي لهذه القمه
وان كانت اقرب الى معالم رئيسيه لهذه
القمه كانت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه كما
شرمها تتحدث عن ان معظم القاضي يدينون
الحرب في اوكرانيا هذا البيان صحيح مئه
بالمئه ولكن بيانات من هذا النوع لا تصدر
الا بالاجماع عندنا متحدث عن بيان لانه
هذا بيان وليس همم مجرد قرارات همم فهي
بيانات وبالتالي همم اداره الحرب في
اوكرانيا ولكن في مستويات مختلفه تتعلق
بكل دوله وموقفه من هذا الحرب اضافه الى
ما ذكرته الوكاله من ان تهديد باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه امر غير قولوا هذا امر
متفق عليه ما بين كل القاده المشاركين في
هذه القمه بما في ذلك الموقف الروسي وان
تاثير الحرف اوكراني على الاقتصاد العالمي
كبير وخطير وهذا شيء متفق عليه ربما هذا
المحور هو مدعا الرئيس الصيني
بان او دعوته بان يتم همم استخدام السلاح
والوقود كسلاح خاصه في ظل
تراجعا ده ذات الطاقه العالميه بسبب الحرف
في اوكرانيا اضافه الى همم الامن الغذاء
وهنا نشير الى الدعوات التي تكررت منذ امس
على لسان
العام للامم المتحده وتكررت ايضا من خلال
قمه العشرين اليوم في الدعوه الى الى
تمديد او اعاده العمل بقرار تصدير الحبوب
من اوكرانيا طبعا بالكثير هناك الكثير من
المواقف التي ربما بانتظار ان تصدر بيانات
وقرارات رسميه من قمه العشرين هنا في
بالهرش
حوار مهم اا محمد منذ قليل مع المتحدث
الاقليمي للخارجيه الامريكيه وسالته بشكل
واضح على مساله مسار للمفاوضات ما بين
روسيا واوكرانيا هل يدور في الكواليس وانت
تتابع الجلسات والفاعليات حديث اوسع حول
هذا الامر
القمه
الجي تونتي القمه التي عقدت بين الرئيس
الصيني والرئيس الامريكي عشيه انطلاق قمه
الجيت وانت في بالي بالتاكيد الكل كان
يتوقع هذه القمه ولكن لم يكن احد يتوقع ان
تكون القمه بهذه الايجابيه بهذه التصريحات
المتفائله بالحديث عن اللقاء الذي اجريته
قبل قليل على الهواء مباشره على شاشه
العربيه مع المتحدث الاقليم في الجسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه
سامبل بالتاكيد كان حديث من دبلوماسيان
بامتياز ولكن هناك همم انعكاس لهذا الحديث
عن تفاؤل ايجابي امريكي في ما يتعلق
بالمستقبل العلاقه الامريكيه الصينيه
المراقبون هنا يشيرون بان الولايات
المتحده حدث اوروبا او ربما اوروبا كانت
بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده بادرت الى
تقارب مع الصين في سبيل ممارسه المزيد من
الضغوط على روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا
ولكن هناك ربما محاوله من قبل الطرفين
لتهديد الصراع خاصه بان هذا التنافس
الاقتصادي ما بين الولايات المتحده والصين
يؤثر بشكل كبير على الاقتصاد العالمي وهنا
تخوف وتحضيرات من ان يكون العام القادم 20
23 عام سيئ جدا على الامن الغذائي على
الاقتصاد العالمي ايضا في ظل دعوات من
الحد من تداعيات رفع سعر الفائده التي
اشار اليها الرئيس الصيني عالميا و شير
الى هنا انه هناك العديد من اللقاءات
الثنائيه هناك اللقاء جامعه الامير محمد
بن سلمان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
هناك قمه اخرى هذه المره الصينيه صدر عنها
بعض من البيانات
محكمه قال ايه همم مكرون وشيء يتقال على
تمويل الدول الاكثر ضعفا وتسويه الديون
السياديه مع استخدام او منع استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه في الحرفيه اوكرانيه ولك
ربما من الامور المهمه التي صدرت هذا
الاجتماع هو والدعوه صريحه من مايكرون
للرئيس الصيني بالضغط على روسيا من اجل
ايجاد حل وتسويه على روسيا من اجل
روسيا الى تصريحات الاخيره التي صدرت من
موسكو بشان التصريحات التي ذكرت او ذكرها
الرئيس الوكراني والتي تحدث عنها بالضروره
سحب جميع القوات الروسيه وتشكيلات
العسكريه قبل الحديث عن السلام هنا موسكو
قالت بان هذه التصريحات لقمه العشرين لا
تنوم عن رغبه حقيقيه من قبل كيف في العوده
الى طاوله المفاوضات الوصول
هذه القمه
وزيره تمثيل هنا لروسيا على مستوى وزير
الخارجيه هل تمت اي اللقاءات الثنائيه بين
اطراف مختلفه وما بين لابروف ان بدات
روسيا منعزله في هذه القمه ان صح التعبير
باعنا في الصوره انت تتابع الكواليس
معزوله خلال هذه القمه هناك جهود واضحه
لوزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لابروف خاصه
بعد الانباء التي تحدثت عن حاله الصحيه
بالامس وظهوره اليوم في استقبال الرئيس
ودود له في مستقل هذه القمه التي تعقد
حاليا في بالي هناك محاولات بالفعل من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي من اجل الضغط على روسيا وعزل
روسيا بل وتحميلها كافه المسؤوليه فيما
يتعلق بهزمه الغذاء الطاقه وكل ما يتعلق
بازمات العالم ربما لكن هناك مواقف روسيه
واضحه وهناك محاولات اندونيسيه اوضح في
محاوله لمسك العصا من النص ما بين المعسكر
الشرقي والمعسكر الغربي خاصه فيما يتعلق
بصراع في اوكرانيا
من جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه حيث متابعه حيه
لفعاليات هذه القمه ال 20 شكرا لك محمد
وسن معكم بالطبع لمتابعه بقيه الفعليه
[موسيقى]
والمتابعه القضايا الاقتصاديه المهمه
المطروحه على اجنده هذه القمه ينضم الينا
من الرياضه الكاتب الاقتصاديه راشد
الفوزان مرحبا بك يا سيد هذه قمه ربما هي
في الاساس اقتصاديه ولكن التداعيات نتيجه
احداث سياسيه نتيجه الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه هل تعتقد ان اجتماع القاده يمكن
ان يضع حدا لبعض الامور الحياتيه الصعبه
التي يعيشها المواطن في اوروبا
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في امريكا وهي
القضيه المتعلقه بالتضخم وارتفاع الاسعار
صباح الخير صباح الخير انا اعتقد انه
الاشكاليه الكبرى في الولايات المتحده
والصين اللي يعتقد انه مهما كانت اللقاء
او تصالحات وقد لا تنتهي الى وفاه حقيقي
باعتبار ان هناك مشكله في همم الاقتصاد
بين امريكا والولايات المتحده في الميزان
التجاري باعتبار الولايات المتحده تضغط في
هذا الجانب من عهد الرئيس ترامب في مساله
همم تخفيض مساله التصدير من الصين باعتبار
من الفائز الان دائما يرجح لصالح الصين
بنسبه كبيره بمعنى ان كل صادرات تصل الى
100 مليار الى الولايات المتحده وهناك عجز
في الميزان التجاري يصل الى 30 او 27% من
العجز في الاقتصاد الامريكي وبالتالي
الصادرات الصينيه يعتبر عاليه جدا همم
الولايات المتحده تعتبر الصين الان هي
مصنع العالم صراحه ولا يمكن هل هذا الوفاق
في العالم باعتقالي الا في سد الفجوه في
ميزان التجاري بين الوزن المتحده وامريكا
سوري الصين لان الصين تعتبر هي اكبر مصدر
للولايات المتحده وهناك فجوه كبيره جدا في
الصادرات لو لحقنا في مثلا الربع او مشرف
ب 4 شهور الاولى من هذا العام لوجدنا
النمو الصادرات الصينيه 15% الى 184 او
185 مليار الصادرات الامريكيه ارتفعت فقط
اقل من واحد في المئه بنسبه 60.8 مليار
والعجز يقارب 124 مليار هذا فقط في اربع
شهور الاولى هذه الفجوه الكبيره هي
المشكله الاساسيه في الاقتصاد العالمي بين
الولايات المتحده والصين بلس مش مشكله
اوكرانيا ومشكله روسيا مشكله الصين مشكله
تايوان المشكله الطاقه في العالم
ثلاث ولا ارقام التى اشرت اليها السيد
راجل هل ترتفع فعلا المخاوف بشان الركود
الاقتصادي لان هذا الامر ستكون له تداعيات
كبيره على الجميع ليس امريكا والصين فقط
ممكن يحصل بنسبه كبيره جدا لانه السياسه
النقدي لك تبع البنك الفدرالي الان هي
استمراريه رفع سعر فائده لو كان هناك
عمليه تحجيم لمساله التضخم اللي هو الان
لب المشكله في العالم وتضخم العالمي
فبالتالي هذه الاشكاليه لم تنتهي وبالتالي
رفع الفائده اللي اخر ما رفع الفائده اربع
مرات حوالي 75 نقطه
وهناك احتماليه في ديسمبر وايضا يستمر الى
الربع الاول من 2020 بمعنى ان نتجاوز
مستويات 5% فبالتالي استمراريه الركود
يعني اعتقد انها قد تكون اتيه لكن هناك
بسيط جدا بسيط اللي هو مثلا انه انخفاض
نسبه التضخم في اكتوبر الماضي في الولايات
المتحده كانت تتوقعات السابع فاصله تسعه
لكن اللي تحقق سبع فاصله 7% وبالتالي سلوك
المستهلك القوه الشرعيه
لكن لم تنتهي الى الان
الى هذه النقطه تحديدا اسعار الفائده وعدم
الاعتماد بشكل كبير في حل مساله التضخم
ولكنك تعلم سيد راشد انه من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه وكالعاده ان محاوله كبح جماح
التضخم تحتاج في بعض الاحيان اللجوء الى
فكره التعامل بشكل مرعي مع اسعار الفائده
هي السلاح مهم واداه مهمه لكن ليست كل شيء
العالم يحتاج الى الاستقرار يحتاج الى حل
اشكالياته حل المشكله الولايات المتحده مع
الصين في مثلا الاقتصاديه ثم لاند دخلت في
الخط بوضع ثاني يعتبر لن تكون هناك تشكيله
كبيره لكن الاشكال الكبير في الخلل في
ميزان التجاري المتحده والصين لكن سيظل
موضوع الاستمراريه رفع الفائده هي اداه
واحده لكن العالم يحتاج الى رفع الانتاج
تحتاج الى المزيد من المعروف يحتاج الى
مزيد من الاستقرار وبالتالي تكون هناك حل
اشكاليه والركود اعتقد لن يكون كثيرا يعني
يتجاوز مستويات منتصف عام 23
متحدثا الينا من الرياض تحياتي
اهلا المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه صامويل برجر العربيه عبر لقاء
خاص ان الولايات المتحده تسعى الا تتحول
المنافسه مع الصين الى صراع وان
الدبلوماسيه مع الصين لا بديل لها
نحن كما سمعنا من
رئيسين على هذه العلاقه و نحن نرهب
المنافسه بين الولايات المتحده والسن ولا
نريد ان نرى هذه المنافسه تذهب الى السرعه
من جانبنا ليس هناك اي سبب اي من هذه
الملفات ال- ال- القلق لدينا حول اي توتر
عبر الموديل تايوان او الوداع مع الكوريه
الشماليه ليس هناك اي سبب من اي من هذه
الملفات وتحديات تؤدي الى سرعه
في تواصل بين الولايات المتحده والحكومه
الصينيه
هذا وتفعل الولايات المتحده الى ادراج
ادانه الحرب في اوكرانيا في البيان
الختامي لقمه مجموعه ال 20 بسبب تاثيرها
على الاقتصاد العالمي وقال مسؤول امريكي
ان الولايات المتحده ستؤكد لمجموعه
العشرين ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي اصل
المعاناه الاقتصاديه وعدم استقرار
الاقتصاد العالمي ككل ورفض المسؤول
الامريكي تحديدا الشكل الذي ستتخذه
الادانه او كيف ستشير اليها في البيان
الختامي وكنا وزير الخارجيه الروسي السرج
الى الابراج اعرب عن رفض موسكو طرح مسائل
الامن والسلام في قمه ال 20 مشيرا الى
الطابع الاقتصادي للقمه واهميه طرح
القضايا التجاريه ذات الاولويه
ملفه الحرب الاوكرانيه احد اكبر الملفات
في قمه الدليل وفي هذا السياق خطب الرئيس
الاوكرانيه قمه العشرين حيث شدد على ضروره
انهاء الحرب التي وصفها بالمدمر في بلاده
كما اكد ذلك ضروره تمديد العمل باتفاق
تصدير الحبوب الذي ينتهي عمده
لا توجد اعذار لممارسه الابتزاز النووي
كما اسماء مقترحا اليه لتبادل لجميع
السجناء مع روسيا
هذا وقلم وفوض شؤون الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبيه جوزه البوري لان
الاتحاد سيطلق يوم الجمعه مهمه التدريب 15
الف جنديا اوكرانيا واضاف بريل قبيله
اجتماعي للوزراء خارجيه والدفاع الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بروكسيل ان قوه التدخل
السريعه الاوروبيه ستكون جاهزه في عام
2025 كما اكد ضروره ان تعمل الدول
الاوروبيه معا لتعويض مخزونها العسكري بعد
دعم اوكرانيا
ونبقى معكم في سياق النشاط الظهيره ومن
العربيه ولدينا
الولايات المتحده تدين الهجمات الايرانيه
على اقليم كردستان العراق وتعتبرها
انتهاكا لسياده العراقيه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى تطورات ملف اليمن
اعلنت البحريه
من ايران الى اليمن وقالت البحريه
الامريكيه في بيان ان الوقود الذي تم ضبطه
يكفي لاطلاق اكثر من 10 صواريخ بالستيه
مشيره الى ان اعمال التهريب غير القانونيه
التي تقوم بها ايران ملحوظه ولا تمر مرور
الكرام وخطيره وغير مسؤوله كما تؤدي الى
انتشار العنف وعدم الاستقرار في الشرق
الاوسط
وينضم الينا من القاهره المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اليمنيه العقيد يحيى ابو
حاتم مرحبا بك سيد يحيى ربما من يستمع الى
هذه الانباء يقول ان هذه دليل جديد ولكن
هناك سلسله من الادله يمكن رصها في تمويل
ايران ميليشيا الحوثي ومع ذلك حتى الان لا
يجوز البعض ان هناك رد فعل قويه من
المجتمع الدولي اتجاه هذا الامر هل هذا
الاعتقاد صحيح
هو ما ذكرتي اختي العزيزه حقيقه هناك ادله
كثيره على تورط ايراني في دعم جماعه
الحوثيين بل
ذهب الكثير الى القول بان جماعه الحوثي
ليست الا فصيل من فصائل الحرس الثوري الذي
انشى خارج حدود دوله ايران هذا الجماعه
تتلقى دعما لا محدودا سواء عسكريا او
اللوجستيا او اعلاميا وماليا من قبل ايران
وما همم يعني يتم ضبط من الاسلحه المهربه
في عرض البحر ليس الا واحد في المئه من
الاسئله التي تدخل للمليشيات الحوثيه هناك
طرق تستخدم من قبل المهربين الذين
يتعاملون مع النظام الايراني لتهريب
الاسلحه همم للاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
جماعه الحوثي منهم جماعه المستبصرون وهم
افارقه
يستخدمهم ايران في تعريب الاسلحه ايضا
هناك مهربون يمنيون وكذلك مهربون همم يعني
لديهم خبره كبيره في تهريب الايه
سيد يحيى بخبراتك الامنيه تقول البحريه
الامريكيه انها قامت بضبط اسلحه تكفي
لاطلاق 10 صواريخ بالستيه كيف يمكن
التعامل مع هذا الامر وما هي الجهه التي
كان سيتم فيها استخدام هذه الصواريخ هل هو
الصراع على الاراضي اليمنيه ام ان هذه
صواريخ يمكن ان تكون موجهه لاهداف
الاستراتيجيه اخرى
والخبراء الذين يديرون اطلاق هذه الاسلحه
واعاده التجميعها وكذلك يعني وضع الوجود
المخصص والاطلاق الصواريخ يتم تهريبهم عن
طريق الحديده الذي يفترض ان تكون موارد
تجاريه لكنها تحولت الى موانعه عسكريه
وكذلك موانع التهريب كل ما يضل امد الحرب
في اليمن ويستهدف الدول والملاحه البحريه
بلا شك اخت العزيزه اليوم جماعه الحوثي لا
تهدد الداخل اليمني وهذه الصواريخ
البالستيالات كلها ابناء الشعب اليمني فقط
ولكنها اليوم جماعه اصبحت تهديد عابر
للحدود واصبحت تهدد منابع الطاقه في دول
الجوار وكذلك تهدد الاملاح البحريه وهناك
يعني عمليات نفذتها جماعه الحوثي بدعم
ايران في استهداف التجاره الدوليه داخل
البحر الاحمر عن طريق زراعه الالغام عن
طريق ارسال الزواج المفخخه كذلك الطائرات
المسيره التي باتت اليوم يعني تقتل ابناء
الشعب اليمني وتهدد ايضا المنابع الطاقه
وبالتالي نحن نتكلم على يا جماعه ارهابيه
يعني جعلت من الاراضي اليمنيه التي تسيطر
عليها كائده متقدمه لايران تهدد امن
استقرار المنطقه وبالتالي عندما نتكلم على
هذه الاسلحه وعلى ماهيه الاهداف التي
ستستهدف تلك الاسلحه بلا شك ان هذه
الاسلحه موجهه خارج حدود اليمن وبالتالي
فهي تهديد همم
هذه المره البحريه الامريكيه هي من قامت
بضبط هذه الاسلحه علمتني سفينه متجهه من
ايران الى اليمن وليست قوات التحالف وليست
اي جهه اخرى وبالتالي كيف ستتعامل الاداره
الامريكيه مع هذا المتغير باعتبار ان
البحرين الامريكيه نفسها هي من قامت بضافه
هذه الاسلحه
اخت العزيزه البحريه الامريكيه يعني القت
القبض على الكثير من الشحن الاسلحه يعني
يعني خلال المده ال- ال- ال- المنصرمبه
كان هناك القبض على اسلحه تتكون من اكثر
من قطع الصواريخ بالستيه ايضا اسلحه
كلاشنكوف وقناصات واسلحه النوعيه منها
صواريخ حراريه اكثر من اربع مرات تم القاء
القبض على اسلحه في عرض البحر ولكن ااه
يعني كما تفضلتي في السؤال الاول او في
انجازك في البدايه الاسئله ان المجتمع
الدولي يتعامى على ما تقوم به ايران في
المنطقه اليوم ايران تهدد المنطقه بشكل
مباشر عن طريق استهداف الملاحه في الخليج
العربي عن طريق يعني الدعم الجماعات
الارهابيه هنا وهناك سواء في سوريا او في
العراق او في لبنان او حتى في اليمن التي
باتت اليوم تهدد ايضا ملاحف في البحر
الاحمر وفي الخليج العربي وبالتالي نحن
امام تهديد مباشر من ايران حرب مباشره من
ايران تفتحها وتقودها عبر العذراء
المتواجده لها في المنطقه نعم السيد
العقيد يحيى ابو حاتم المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اليمنيه من القاهره تحياتي
ونبقى معكم في سياق النشاط الظهيره من
العربيه ولدينا
عدد سكان الارض يبلغ ثمانيه مليارات نسمه
وسكان الصين يتراجعون الى 800 مليون
بنهايه القرن وفقا تقريرين امامي
قمه مجموعه الهاشم باندونيسيا ومسوده
البيان الختامي تدعو لتجنب التهديد
بالسلاح النووي
و سعيون امريكيه لادانه الحرب في اوكرانيا
ببيان قمه ال 20 وزنسك يقترح تبادل جميع
السجناء مع روسيا
البحريه الامريكيه تعلن ضبطه 70 طنا من
وقود الصواريخ في قارب المتجه من ايران
الى اليمن
ومن ملفات الظهيره في انتخابات الكونجرس
الامريكيه الجمهوريون على بعده مقعد واحد
فقط من السعاده اغلبيه مجلس النواب
اهلا بكم من جديد
ايران الى وقت هجماتها المتكرره التي
تنتهي كوسيده العراق المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه
الهجمات الايرانيه على اقليم كردستان
العراق والتي استهدفت الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي تتخذ الاقليم مقر
لها
ورضا على هجوم الحرس الثوريه الصاروخيه ضد
مقررات كرديه في كردستان العراق ومقتل
شخصين دعا مركز التعاون الاحزاب
الكردستانيه الايرانيه الشعب الايراني
لدخول في اضراب العام يوم الخميس المقبل
كما طلبت مجموعه شباب احياء زهران من
المواطنين الايرانيين عدم دفع فواتير
المياه والكهرباء والغاز وعدم القيام
بعمليات المصرفيه واغلاق ما تجاريهم ايضا
طلبت مجموعه شباب احياء ايران من
المواطنين مقاطعه الشركات التي تقوم بنشر
الاعلانات في التلفزيون الايراني
الى اقامه تجمعات الاحتجاجيه كبيره وطلبوا
باغلاق المدارس والجامعات وشركات التجاريه
اعتبارا من يوم غدا الاربعاء
وينضم الينا من لندن الباحث في شان
الايرانيه السيد عارف نصر مرحبا بك سيد
عارف على ما يبدو ان الاحتجاجات ستدخل
مرحله جديده تتعلق بما يشبه الاضرابات
العامه هل هذا التقييم صحيح
الكرام الواقع نحن امام الان مرحله جديده
في ما يبدوها بالاحتجاجات التي تشهدها
ايران وهي الانتقال من ربما الاحتجاجات
الى مرحله الاضرابات وصول الى العصيان
المدني
وهو ما ينص عليه ربما
الكثير من التحركات التي تقوم بها الاحزاب
وكذلك حتى
ربما التجمعات التي الان باتت تتخذ من
الاحياء محورا لها وحتى هنالك ربما تحديث
الى التكتيكات بالتعامل مع المتظاهره التي
تشهدها ايران وهي ربما التوجه من الشوارع
الى الميادين العامه وهذا ما دعى همم دعى
له همم
ربما تفسير التنسيقيات الموجوده في
الاحياء المختلفه بالمدن المختلفه ايضا
نعم كيف سيتعامل النظام مع انتقال
الاحتجاجات الى هذه المرحله نحن نتحدث هنا
عند دعوات لاضرابات في اماكن في المسارف
في المدارس في المستشفيات هذه مرحله جديده
اذا كان نظام وفقا لتقارير حقوقيه يتعامل
بالقمع في الشوارع ولكن كيف سيتعامل مع
هذه الاضرابات الجديده
وقت متاخر من الليل فايل صوتي لاحد همم
مساعدين وزير الاستخبارات الايرانيه
افصحها عن مجموعه من الخطط الايرانيه
للتعامل مع المظاهرات وهذا اعتقد بانه هذا
المقطع الصوتي مهم جدا حيث انه يشير الى
في ما يبدو الى مجموعه من الخطط الايرانيه
للتعامل مع المظاهرات اهمها بان سوف تكون
هنالك تعامل همم قاسي مع المتظاهرين
واعتقالات وربما حتى تنفيذ او على الاقل
صدور اعدامات الى المتظاهرين من هنا اعتقد
بان
الحل همم النظام الايراني لا يزال لا يريد
ان يستجيب الى مطالب التي يرفعها
المتظاهرين وعلى الاقل الاستيعاب هذه
المظاهرات ضمن الدستور الايراني بل يريد
ان يتعامل باللامبالاه وربما العقليه
الامنيه التي يمتلكم طيب الدعوات التي
وجهت لمجلس حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم
المتحده لعقد جلسه بشان هذه الانتهاكات في
ايران هل يمكن التعويل عليها
انا احتفظ بان هذا الامر مهم جدا خاصه وان
هنالك في ما يبدو بان تحرك اوروبي شاهدناه
على لسان الرئيس الفرنسي وكذلك همم في
المانيا وكثير من الدول الاخرى لكنما انا
اعتقد بان لا تزال هنالك الملفات ااه مثل
حرب الاوكرانيه ومدى انخراط ايران في هذا
الملف وكذلك حتى الملف النووي لا تزال لها
اولويتها الى الجانب الاوروبي ومن هنا
هذان الملفين يلعبان الدوره الحاسم في
كيفيه التعامل مع موضوع الاحتجاجات الا
اذا كانت هنالك اعتجاجات كبيره تغلب ربما
المصالح الاوروبيه همم على ربما الاستمرار
بهذه بهذين الملفين همم يعني همم الذين
ذكرتهم من هنا انا بان جانب الاوروبي الان
امامه مجموعه من الخيارات اهمها تفعيل
مجموعه من المحاكم الدوليه تجاه النظام
الايراني لكن انما لا استبعد ان يكون هذا
الامر ربما بالقريب العاجل سيحصل
في قضيه الاعدامات الشهيره التي كان لها
تاثير كبير على سمعه النظام الايراني
السيد عارف نصر الباحث في اجانب الايراني
من لندن تحياتي
والى سباق الانتخابات التجديد النصفيه في
امريكا
على مجلس النواب الامريكي ليصبح على بعده
مقعد واحد فقط من تحقيق الاغلبيه حسب
مصادر اعلاميه امريكيه ارتفع عدد مقاعد
الحزب الجمهوري الى 2007 مقعدا مقابل خمسه
مقاعد للديمقراطيين ويتقه 13 مقعدا لم يتم
حسمها حتى الان
الى ذلك حسنه اديموقراطيه كاتيهوبس منصب
حاكم ولايه اريزونا بعد التغلب على
منافساتها الجمهوريه المدعومه من الرئيس
السابق ترامب كاريك كما حسم الحزب
الديمقراطي سباق الاغلبيه بمجلس الشيوخ
بعد فوز المرشح ماركلي على منافسه
الجمهوريه مصر وبذلك استحوذ الحزب
الجمهوري على 50 مقعدا بمجلس الشيوخ
مقابله 49 مقعدا للجمهوريه
وينضم الينا من واشنطن الخبير في شان
الامريكي والباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
السيد ايهاب عباس مرحبا بك سيد ايهاب ربما
يكون العنوان هو مدى واضحا رغم بعض نتائج
التي لم تعلن رسميا ولكن سيطره جمهوريه
على مجلس النواب وسيطره ديموقراطيه على
مجلس الشيوخ لكن الماضي اعتقد ان هذه
النتائج هي نتائج ليست جيده بشكل كبير
بالنسبه للحزب الجمهوري هل هذا صحيح
الحزبه الجمهوري يجب ان يكون سعيدا بمحقق
حتى الان او بما هو في طريقه لتحقيقه وهو
السيطره على مجلس النواب سبب في ذلك من
وجهه نظري ان هذا الحزب خسر كل شيء قبل
عامين خسر الانتخابات الرئاسه خسر
الكانجوس اليوم يعود بعد كل ادعاء
الانتخابيه السيئه التي وجهها ضده من
الحسبه الديمقراطي والمخاوف التي الناجح
الحسبه ديمقراطي في زرعها لدى افكار يعني
عشرات الملايين من المواطنين الامريكيين
بان عوده الحزب الجمهوري تعني عوده الرئيس
دونالد ترامب تعني عوده الفوضى للبلاد
والتعدي على الديمقراطيه هذا ما نجح الحزب
الجمهور الديمقراطي في الدعايه همم له
بشكل كبير جدا وهو ما اهله للاحتفاظ
بمقاعده في مجلس الشيوخ ربما زاد عليهم
كمان وبالتالي همم اليوم الحزب الج عندما
يسيطر على مجلس النواب هذا امر كبير جدا
لماذا لان مجلس النواب هو معانيه في
الاساس بتقديم مشاريع بسن قوانين جديده
تشير الى انها ستكون اكثريه بسيطه وليست
اغلبيه كما هو كان الحال همم في عهود
صادقه
طبعا بكل تاكيد هي ليست همم اغلبيه ساحقه
يعني هي صحيح ستكون اغلبيه بسيطه ربما
بسته مقاعد ربما ب 10 مقاعد على اقصى
تقدير لكن هي مهمه لماذا لان اولا ليس كل
الديمقراطيين يتوافقون مع القرارات
والتشريعات التي يريد ان ان يضعها موضع
التنفيذ الحزب الديمقراطي كذلك الجمهوري
بالمناسبه يعني هناك اعضاء جمهوريون ربما
يرفضون في كثير من الاحيان بعض ان تشريعات
التي تقدم بها الجمهوريون مثلهم ل- همم
لكي تسمى وتصبح قوانين او مواد في الدستور
بعد ذلك همم وبالتالي هذه الاغلبيه
البسيطه الصحيحه وان كانت بسيطه الا انها
ستعيق بشكل او باخر كثير من الخطوط
الديمقراطيه خاصه الرئيس في دعم اوكرانيا
الحزب ال- همم الجمهوري بسيطته على مجلس
النواب سيكون قادرا للحد من هذا الدعم
وتوجيهه في مجالات اخرى داخليه وهذا ما
يريده المواطن الامريكي بشكل كبير
سعيد بهذه النتائج لا يبدو انه قلق رغم ان
البعض يعتقد ان مساره سيعرقل بشكل او باخر
كما ذكرت في بعض الملفات الدوليه
والداخليه ايضا
لانه كان يتوقع والحزب الديمقراطي ان
يخسروا مجلسي النواب والشيوخ لمصلحه
الجمهوريه فعندما يحتفظوا من مجلس الشيوخ
وبمقعه زائد هذا انجاز كبير من وجهه نظري
للحزب الديمقراطي وسيكون الامر بشكل او
باخر مقبول على مستوى السياسه الداخليه
الامريكيه لان سيحدث ما يسمى التوازن وهو
ما كان قد دعى اليه استاذه رشا الى الماسك
يعني ان خبينا الامريكيين عندما قال توجهه
بصناديق الاختراع وينتخبوا الجمهوريين حتى
يكون هناك توازن وهذا افضل لخطط الولايات
المتحده صحيح ان هذا التوازن لن يكون همم
في مصلحه الديمقراطين ولم يكون في مصلحه
الجمهوريه وسيحدث حاله خلال هذين العامين
المتبقيين من رئاسه الرئيس وبيض من
الصراع السياسي الكبير جدا بين الحزبين في
الملفات المهمه وسيف
ولكنها ترامب خسره خاصه لان البعض يعتقد
ان كل من دعم او غالبيه من دعاهم ترامب لم
ينجحوا في هذه الانتخابات
هناك تسويق شديد همم التطرف من
الديمقراطيين ضد الحزب الجمهوري
مستخدمينها الرئيس السابق دون ترامب يعني
هو مسوقه انه سيعود ويعود معه
التغول والتعدي على الديمقراطيه هم يصدقون
الان لهذه الفكره ان كل من دعاهم ترامب لا
ليس كل من دعمهم ترامب هناك كثيرون نجحوا
في مجلس النواب في مجلس الشيوخ بالمناسبه
والرئيس السابق دولاند ترامب ما زال خلفه
ما يخرج من اثنين و70 مليون مواطن يريدون
ان يشاهدونه مره اخرى في البيت الابيض هو
فاز قبل ذلك بهذا العدد وهو تقريبا نصف
القوه الانتخابيه في الولايات المتحده
ويستطيع ان يشكل الفكره اليوم هل سيستطيع
الحزب الجمهوري ان يتوحد خلف مرشح واحد في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه نعم نعم جديد
صحيح صحيح وخاصه ان ترامب خطابه شعبه
مباشره
وهذا الرجل لديه الزخم نوع ماء من خلفه
يدعمه من قبل النخبه السياسيه في الحزب
الجمهوري لكن ترامب لديه هذا الزخم بشكل
او باخر
هذه الانتخابات
ولاني الاخبار الاقتصاد مع زميلته نادين
هاني شكرا باشا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا لنلقي نظره على
تداولات اسواق المنطقه كما ترون اليوم
اللون الاحمر طاغيه على التداولات هلا من
جهه كان عنا تراجعات على امس من ناحيه
اخرى اسيا على ارتفاع اليوم اوروبا بدات
على ارتفاع هذا اغلاق يوم امس من بعد
المكاسب القويه مع نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
سمعنا من اعضاء الفدرالي تهدئه للاسواق
بانه الفيدرالي مستمر بالتشديد ولو بوتيره
اقل ولكن هذا لا يعني انه الحرب على
التضخم من تحت وبالتالي هذا ما ادى الى
بعض التراجع على الاسواق الامريكيه يوم
امس بالاضافه الى اخبار سلبيه من امازون
انها تنوي تسريحه 10,000 موظف سبقها من
متى النيه لتسريح ثلاثه عشر الف موظف مع
ذلك الاسواق الاثيوبيه على ارتفاع لاحظ
الهاجسينج ارتفاع اربعه بالمئه من بعض هذا
اللقاء الذي جمع الرئيس الامريكي ايضا
لنظيره الصيني والحوار الذي جرى اول لقاء
شخص منذ ازمه من بعد التصعيد على الصعيد
الحرب التجاريه بين الاثنين ومنعه كان اخر
خطوه من الولايات المتحده منعت بعض انواع
الميكروت شيبس الرقائق من تصديرها الى
الصين وهذه تؤثر سلبا على تكنولوجيا
الصينيه فاذا اليوم اسهم التكنولوجيا
الصينيه على ارتفاع والهانسانج على مكاسب
قويه هذه الاسواق الاوروبيه ايضا على
ارتفاع اليوم اداء ايجابيه
ربما النفط اللي يتراجع بعض الشيء نقطه عن
93 دولار لمزيج براند بالاضافه الى مجموعه
من نتائج الشركات التي سمعناها اليوم ولم
تكن كلها ايجابيه هذا النفط تحت 93 دولار
هذا ربما يؤثر بعض الشيء السلبا على اسواق
المنطقه خلينا نبدا من السوق بالسعوديه
حيث نرى تبرعات ب 19 نقطه المئويه اليوم
مؤشر السوق يعني 11,000 و100 نقطه تراجعات
حاده بني بها الفتره الاخيره شاكر مرتفع
بسبعه ونص بالمئه سحبت طلب رفع راس مالها
عبر حقوق اولويه من هيئه سوق المال تقول
انه لا حاجه لديها بالوقت الحظر لرفع راس
المال عبر حقوق اولويه ساكو من ضمن الاسهم
المرتفع الزمن للصناعه ايضا اسم بنت
الغسيل اربعه بالمئه ايضا مجموعه هو
الحكير للسياحه كلها على تراجع اليوم بدبي
ان نتراجع بواحد بالمئه نتائج اعمار
العقاريه كانت همم متباينه على صعايده ربح
الصافي ات جيده مليار ونصف ارباح ربع سلس
ارتفاع ب 47% عن نفس الفتره من العام
الماضي ولكن على صعيد الارادات اتتقل من
المتوقع ومتراجع 21% عن نفس الفتره من
العام الماضي المبيعات اعمار تراجعت الى
اثنين فاصل سته مليار درهم ربع ثالث
مقارنه مع اربعه ونصف مليار درهم بالربع
المماثل من العام الماضي عم بحكي عن
المبيعات السكنيه الوحدات السكنيه اعمار
لتطوير ايضا كان عنده تراجع بالارباح 26%
وبالتالي السهمان يضغطون اليوم املاك
للتمويل سجل تراجع 86% بارباح ربع ساعه
ثالث واثنين بالمئه تبريد ارتفاع ثلاثه
بالمئه بالارباح مع ذلك السهم متراجع
وامانات خساره 10.4 مليون درهم ربع الثالث
من السنه هذه كلها تضغط على دولات سوق دبي
ولكن انفعه السهم الجديد الذي ادرج به سوق
دبي اليوم يستحولد على حوالي نصف
التداولات واا يرتفع عن سعر
درهم 33 فلس يتداول على الدرهم 38 فلس
الان رشا عوده اليك الان اللون احمر يعني
نتبعون الاحمر طاغيه للاسف شكرا لك نادين
[موسيقى]
اظهر فيديو جديد نشر على مواقع التواصل
لاحلام البشير السوريه والتي زرعت العبوه
على احد المقاعد في شارع الاستقلال بمنطقه
تقسيم بتركيا وهي تركض مسرعه قبل انفجار
العبوه بدقائق قليله
[موسيقى]
حزن يلف تركيا
وتضامن مع ذوي الضحايا
وشارع الاستقلال يحاول النهوض مجددا بعد
الانفجار هذا هو المشهد الاخير في اسطنبول
بعد التفجير الذي خلف عشرات القتلى
والجرحى
تصادف وجود صاحب محل تصفيف الشعر هذا مع
موظفه في المحل لحظه التفجير
عده امطار فقط كانت تفصيلهم عن مكان
انفجار القنبله ناجه جميعا لكن مشهد
الشضايا والهلع الذي عاشوه ما زال ماثنا
امامهم منذ الحادثه
الان الحمد لله هو بساحه جيده كانت لدينا
ادرار لكن ستعودنا الدوله
بشتغل هون في الصالون هون حلاقه الحادثه
صارت ما يقول الصالون بالضبط يعني ما في
20 متر نحنا انا قبل بدقيقه قدام الصالون
طلعت لفوق الصالون لسه ما عرفت لاول
الصالون كان صاير الانفجار عند اول ما
طلعت من الصالون طلعت هيك لبرا العالم
جيب سامسونج
لكني رايت الناس تجري الكل يرقد في جميع
الاتجاهات عند نهوض شربت الماء ثم بدات
سيارات الاسعاف والاطفاء بالوصول بعدها
اغلقنا المحل وذهبنا للبيت
السلطات التركيه اكدت اعتقال عشرات
المرتبطين بالتفجير من بينهم امراه سوريه
تدعى احلام البشير زراعه القنبله تحت احد
المقاعد في شارع الاستقلال دخلت تركيا
بطريقه غير مشروعه من عفرين السوريه
الاتهام الرسمي الوحيد ووجهها لحزب العمال
كردستاني ومن تسميه انقر الفرع السوري
للحزب حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي لكن
المقاتلين الاكراد ينفون الاتهام
وفقا لطبيعه وتوقيت تفجير شارع الاستقلال
فانه لن يمر دون توظيفه في المشهد السياسي
التركي خصوصا مع قرب الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيات المقبله من شارع
الاستقلال في اسطنبول زيدان زينجو العربيه
للتنظيم الاسلامي وفق مصادر العربيه وذلك
بعد اعلانهم تشكيل قوه عسكريه تمثل
الاقاليم التي لم تكون فصائل المسلحه
الزميله لينا يعقوب والتفاصيل
السودان ساكنين في عنبر واحد ما بنعرف
ده يوسف جنون
كلنا كمان بيجمعنا
تجمعنا القوات المسلحه
المتتاليه للقائد العام للجيش السوداني
لقواته بان لا فرق بين جندي واخر بسبب
قبيلته او ولايته ظهرت بصوره المفاجئه وفي
العلم مجموعه عسكريه مكونه من ضباط
متقاعدين ومجموعات قبليه اطلقوا على
انفسهم قوات كيان الوطن هدفهم ان يصبح قوه
موازيه للولايات التي لم تكون فصائل مسلحه
تجمع عسكري في المقام الاول عسكري عند
قوات اخواننا لعمل توازن
الولايات التي كونت لها مجموعات مقاتله
وقعدت بها او تمكنت بها من الاستيلاء على
مقاعد ثابته في الوزاره
التي حصلت عليها العربيه انهم 16 ضابطا
متقاعدا بينهم سته من المنتمين للتنظيم
الاسلامي اما الاعداء والضخمه التي تحدث
عنها فهي مجموعات قبليه ومناطقيه ترى انها
مهمشه وايضا حركات متمرده لم تجد حظها من
السلطه والثروه احزاب السياسيه معارضه
للمكون العسكري رفضت هذه الخطوات
[موسيقى]
قوات ايا كان اسمها فهذا عمل مرفوض لا
نؤيده ولا نقبله
رغم ان دلاله الشخصيات وتوقيت التدشير
خلاف للمحود ورغم خطوره الفكره واعتقال من
طبقوها الا ان محللين وخبراء عسكريين
قللوا من اهميتها
الامن الوطني
وبالتالي تنتهي هذه
الحدوته في تاريخ السودان
عشرات من الحركات المسلحه في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه استقوت بالقبيله
والسلاح تحت مسمه التهميش فهل تعقد هذه
المحاكاه من اخرين المشهد السياسي
والامنيه المتازم لن يعقوب العربيه
الخرطوم
وننتقل مع حضراتكم لكلمه رئيس الامريكيه
جو بايدن في قمه العشرين المنعقده في بالي
بي اندونيسيا
من اجل الانتقال للطاقه النظيفه يمكننا ان
نضمننا ان هذا سوف يعود بالنفع على الشعوب
كافه ليس فقط في الدول
ليس فقط في الدول الناميه بل في الدول
المتطوره وهي هنا بالتحالف في الدول التي
عملت على مرحله
اقامته شراكه الانتقال للاطاقه النظيفه
بصوره همم
متساويه وكذلك هناك جهود ضد التجري على
اقامه
تحالفات الماليه للوصول الى انبعاثات
الكربونيه
بمستويات منخفضه
ان نقوم بنشر 20 مليار دولار من اجل دعم
جهودي اندونيسيا للخفضه
على الطاقه المتجدده ونقوم بدعم الاعمال
الجهات التي تعمل على تحقيق هذا الهدف
الانتقالي لاضافه 20000
حضرتك
[موسيقى]